thank you a now now for someone to read
the Best Actress nominations we went to
a two-time Oscar winner who is on
location in Mexico there he is the Abe
Lincoln of the sagebrush mr. Gary Cooper
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you John Wilkes Booth down here in
Mexico or just by was excited about the
awards tonight as you are at home so
let's see those are nominated for the
Best Performance by an actress our
Leslie Caron in Lily metro-goldwyn-mayer
Ava Gardner in Mogambo
metro-goldwyn-mayer Audrey Hepburn in
Roman Holiday Paramount Deborah Carr in
From Here to Eternity Columbia
Maggie McNamara in the moon is blue
Preminger Herbert production United
Artists and the winner is
well I better turn you over to the Abe
Lincoln of the bobby-soxer oh thank you
very thank you very much yep very proud
you will not forsake me oh my darling
you'll get all the money let me see here
Gary I'm gonna take over for you should
I read it should I read it I don't think
I will
ladies and gentlemen in New York City
miss Audrey Hepburn in Ramat Hollow
too much I want to say thank you to
everybody
we need past months and years have
helped guided and given me so much and
truly truly grateful I can't be happy
[Applause]